[Music starts] [Audio Description - not captioned]
[Teresa Przytycka, PhD] My research focuses
on building computational methods to address
problems in in biomedical sciences.
We are particularly interested in
developing new methods to study diseases,
with particular interest actually in cancer.
Before, people have been looking at diseases
from the perspective - okay, here's a gene,
something wrong happened to this
gene, and you have a disease.
But complex diseases does not work this way.
The usual is something happened to this
pathway, something happened to this
process. And when something happened
to this process, you have a disease.
It's not so easy to identify the
pathway, when you look gene-by-genes,
because it may be that every
individual perturbation,
when you look from gene-by-genes perspective,
is very small and it's hard to capture.
But when you understand that you are to
look at the pathway in group of genes,
the signals gets amplified, and
you may be able to identify
processes that you wouldn't see if
you would look at the genes in isolation.
So we are trying to look at the diseases from
the perspective of this regulated pathways.
Some of our recent study in cancer research are
related to understanding of the relationship
between mutations patients may
have and say drug response.
Assume that we identify a
pathway, we can ask the question
"does the patient has a mutation in
this pathway?", and this gives us some
way of predicting whether or not
individual will responds to drug.
Those questions are indeed very much
driven by personalized medicine.
I think that the goal would be some of the methods
that I've developed will have a really lasting
effect and also that some of the biological
findings would be important for human health.
[Music and audio description continues without captions]
[Music continues]
[Music fades to silence]